My husband's been on a real ice cream cake lately.
We ran out of ice cream,
so I decided to combine two of his favourite things,
ice cream and cinnamon rolls,
and make a cinnamon roll ice cream.
Heated my milk mixture on the stove
while I combined all of my egg yolks
and gave that a good whisk before pouring in some of that hot milk.
Then I transfer all of that back to the stove
and let it thicken a little bit
before adding it to a bowl with some heavy cream.
Make sure to strain it just to get all the bits out.
I added some vanilla and some more cinnamon
before covering it with cling film
and setting it in the fridge for a few hours.
In the meantime, I made my cinnamon roll dough with some butter,
some sugar, use some whole wheat flour,
a little bit of milk, and obviously some more cinnamon.
I let that go until it all came together in a cohesive dough
before transferring it over to a bowl.
I place this in the fridge until my mixture was cool.
Right before churning my ice cream,
I made a quick cinnamon swirl
that I would drizzle on top of the ice cream.
Once all of my ingredients were prepped,
I turned on my ice cream Turner and poured in my ice cream mixture.
I let that go until it thickened up
before adding my cinnamon roll dough
and letting that Go for another few minutes.
Once it looked like soft serve,
I transferred it over to my storage container.
It needed a little bit more,
so I drizzled it with my cinnamon swirl
and some more of the dough that was left over,
and then it was ready to go in the freezer for a few hours.
By this time, both lucky and I couldn't wait any longer.
So we had it. And it was so good that he stole that bowl,
and I made myself another bowl.
The different textures were so perfect,
he actually ended up finishing that whole tray of ice cream.
So I'm making a new batch.